[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
let's talk talk about our democracy for
a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him so is she going
to
juice maybe she's going to suck the
juice out of Colorado's forth I don't
know maybe she'll go Lind Colorado's for
the
hand what a bunch of [__]
losers what a bunch of [__]
losers that you have to switch districts
because you're going to get your ass
stomped because you gave a handy in the
theater that that that's literally the
why she's got to
move I mean she was like 500 votes over
Adam Frisk he's going to run again he's
outraising her like crazy which
Democrats are out raising Republicans
everywhere because no one wants to lend
their money to the party of the dict
taster and here we have a dict taster
wannabe not the one in Mar Lago the one
in Colorado's third currently wants to
go suck the juice out of Colorado's
fourth I don't know what maybe there's a
theater in the fourth district maybe
there's a theater in the fourth district
I don't
know but she gives a lame excuse of a
video online now this is all at the
direction of the mango musolini Jesus I
mean you know that because they know
they're going to lose that district and
it's not about it's not so much about
how many cuz I know I know people think
that they're trying to count like to get
a majority but their majority is gone
their chance of a majority is gone I
don't know if you've noticed this but a
lot of these maps have been changing in
these state courts and it's all swinging
towards the
Democrats chances of
increasing their majority in the house
which is going to make AEM jeffes the
speaker alls they're trying to do alls
they're trying to do with getting Lauren
bobert to go over and suck the juice out
of the Colorado
forth I I there might be I don't know
maybe beetle juu is playing over there I
don't
know what they're trying to do is keep
the Republican caucuses IQ as low as
possible is what they're trying to
do because Trump's going to lose in 2024
MAA is going to lose in 2024 it's not
you remember the Red Wave they were
going to have in
2022 and it was like a a a light pink
drip you remember this it's it's going
to swing back which swinging back from a
red wave in
2022 after they after Grandpa Hitler is
claiming he killed roie Wade which he
did and they're taking away women's
rights and people are clearly not into
that
and then you have the Queen the queen of
Latter poers Lauren bobert going to
switch districts to Ken Buck because Ken
Buck is retiring this is all an effort
to keep Trump supporters and to keep
Trump lunatics in the house so they'll
say crazy [__] on the floor and in
committees that's what this
is it's just an attempt only to keep the
IQ low in the Republican caucus that's
it
period and they don't give a [__] about
Lauren
bobert she C listen when you have
someone like her that can raise money
because she raises money her and
Marjorie Taylor green are big
fundraisers because they milk every
single penny out of all the qinon L
lunatics in the
country and they give it all to the
[__] you know Grandpa
Hitler I mean that's how Lauren Marjorie
Taylor green she bought off she bought
off Kevin
McCarthy with
fundraising what what do you think this
is all about you think this is because
they're good Congress people and they
get things for their constituents done
in their districts get the [__] out of
here these people are bragging about
infrastructure that Democrats and Biden
passed that they said was going to
destroy our country and they're taking
credit for that
infrastructure the money that's going
into their districts these people don't
give a [__] about their constituents
they don't give a [__] about Americans
they don't give a [__] about us
otherwise they wouldn't be in the
Republican party and they definitely
wouldn't be supporting Grandpa Hitler
the dict taster [__] out of
here this is all about their
power and their lies and their ability
to use their power to tell their lies on
government official our government's
official record in the House of
Representatives that's what the is cuz
they know they've lost the Senate When
Donald Trump loses in 2024 because he is
going to [__]
lose we are G to stomp his [__]
little diaper filled ass okay I'm tired
of this [__] liberal [__] where
they're terrified of that [__] I
am not scared of him frankly I want him
on the
ballot I want him on
there I want to go head-to-head with
these manga fascist mother [__]
I want to go head to-head oh I'm ready
for the new year baby I'm [__]
ready it's going to be a hell of a year
oh man it's going to be so much
winning ah
winning it's going to be so much I'm so
excited I'm [__] I'm pumped I'm
pumped for
2024 a lot of people are like oh my God
what's going to happen oh know is he
going to go to triy on March 4th is they
going to put him on the ballot he better
put him on the goddamn ballot I want to
go vote against that
[__] that's right I'm not voting
for Joe Biden I'm not voting for Joe
Biden I'm not I'm voting against
fascism all the way up and down that
[__] ticket against fascism
first oh hey that's a good idea they got
America First they're a little Nazi
saying I don't know if you know the
history of America
first but it was the entry of fascism in
the midcentury ho ho ho the KKK would
carry around America First Signs trying
to convince people that oh fascism good
Hitler
good they're poisoning the blood of our
country he says it different yeah he
said it in
German I'm fired up
I want him on the
ballot we have to clearly beat Fascism
and MAA in this
country and this Lauren bobert move to
where she's going to
go suck the juice out of Colorado's
forth in a primary which she'll probably
lose get excited about that you're
you're going to get you're going to get
the support of Republican against
against Lauren board get excited about
that [__] yeah watch her losing a
primary can you
imagine Lauren
bobert losing in a [__]
primary think about
it this is going to be [__] great a
great
year think about the possibility because
this is a real possibility
that they will chant at Trump Nazi
rallies we want a dictator we want a
dictator we want a dictator they're
probably going to be chanting that [__]
actually you know what it's not a bad
idea we should probably get some plants
you know we should do an OP you know
what I mean that way they can really
blame it on us because that's what
they're going to do they're like oh
there's Democrats in the crowd
encouraging people it was the FBI the
Deep state was they're trying to
encourage people to chant we want a
dictator so I mean we should just go
ahead and do it they're going to blame
it on us anyways why not have antifa
there on the ground you know what I mean
maybe I'll bring it up in the uh this
week's antifa
meeting in on that secret little place
that we
meet actually you know our antifa meets
every week every [__] day every
weekday antifa meets right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast this is the antifa
meeting May I should build it that way I
don't know I'm just thinking here just
thinking out loud I'm having fun it's
going to be a great year I'm very
optimistic I'm feeling really good about
the future of this country and I know I
know I know a lot of people and a lot of
Liberals are [__] get getting the air
sucked out of their hot air balloon but
that's because liberals who listen to
dumb liberals and dumb
commentators stupid commentators stupid
commentary just saying [__] just to
[__] say it because it says it on the
boob tube well the media is saying that
Nicki Haley's going to win get the [__]
out of here with this nonsense I told
you weeks ago that Nikki Haley ain't got
a shot in
hell she she ain't gonna win
period [__] take it to the bank if
you want to go bet on it she ain't going
to win she's just as weird and just as
[__] dumb as Rhonda santis and she's
a woman in the Republican party what the
[__] are what the [__] is any
commentator out there worth their weight
saying that Nikki Haley can win that's
the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
of
dumbest and if you're listening to
people who are telling you Nicki Haley's
got a shot you need to stop listening to
them because they're full of [__]
[__]
they're just saying it cuz it's popular
on Twitter oh TW Nicki Haley's trending
on Twitter so I'll make a video saying
that she gonna win she gonna beat Trump
people will really feel good if I lie to
him and tell them that Nicki Haley will
beat Trump she ain't gonna win what the
[__] are you this is like Ronda santis
okay this is what they're saying they're
like hey man Nicki Haley's coming up in
the polls she's been like I don't know I
know like like 3% like 3% and and she's
getting all the corporate money who do
you what do you think Ronda santis
did what what the [__] do you think
Ronda Sis's campaign
was big [__] Republican donors trying
to box out Donald Trump that [__] didn't
work not with Ronda santis how do you
think it's going to work with Nikki
Haley when she's talking about how she's
avoiding questions of the Civil War and
slavery okay yeah all right that's going
to be a big
winner big winner Nikki Haley is next
question I'd like to ask Nikki Haley
some questions maybe I'll ask her some
questions like we're going to watch the
uh the clip of her trying to skurred
around questions about slavery what do
you want me to say about
slavery we'll see what she uh we'll see
what she
says but I'm fired up I'm fired up and
I'm ready to go for 2024 we're going to
do this [__] you know
that that's right and anyone out there
being pessimistic [__] stomp their
ass and tell them to get over here to
this show because we ain't going to be
pessimistic about next year it's going
to be all it's going to be all strategic
outrage pointed at saving our democracy
at the battlefield of The Ballot
Box and we're going to engage to save it
we're going to do what democracies do
and that's and that's kill fascism [__]
them [__]
them so you're either you're either on
the Optimus train and you're ready to
beat these son of a
[__] because it ain't listen you know
I get this [__] too I hav ever heard
this they're like well how many times do
we have to vote how many times oh Tony
how many times do we have to vote them
out we're going to have to vote them out
forever like every single election from
now until ever you're going to have to
keep voting against
fascist fascism is an idea it's an
ideology and really it's kind of a loose
ideology because they adopt all kinds of
crazy ass [__] conspiracy theories
along the way and they adopt all kinds
of [__] lies and misinformation and
different Power interests along the way
so it's not always the same exact
[__]
thing the fascism that we saw in the
1970s and 80s in this country when
Ronald Reagan Rose to power when he used
the [__] the racist white vote in the
South so that he could give tax cuts to
his Rich [__]
friends and absolutely obliterate
American workers by by shipping jobs
overseas and making sure that the
managers and the bit higher ups in the
companies got all the [__]
GDP that kind of fascism it's a little
different than the one now isn't it when
their nominee is standing on stage
saying I'm not saying the same thing
Hitler said he said it different he said
it in German godamn
it and then everyone outside in the
Sheep pins all the [__] sheep are
like we want a dictator we want a
dictator yeah Trump 2024 Grandpa
Hitler you think that's going to be hard
to
beat oh [__] this is so funny it's funny
it's funny even people who voted for
Trump twice listen to me listen to me
really closely even people who voted for
Trump twice when they hear people would
rather have Trump as a dictator than
sleepy Joe
Biden as president old man old man
Brandon as president they're going to
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
of in my life that's the most unamerican
thing cuz folks I know right now it
doesn't feel like it but he's just
getting started on this Hitler and
dictator stuff he's just getting
started he's just getting started to get
the cult to acknowledge that they want
him to be a
dictator he's just getting started on
that he's going to go way way further
than he has before hell he'll probably
go way further than I even
imagine and I I see stuff more clearly
than most commentators because I don't
let the [__] and the noise get in my
way of seeing what is [__] real and
what's not like Nikki Haley is going to
beat him get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense as soon as soon as she
announced that she was running you can
go back and look at it the day that she
announced I said she will not
win no way not a chance in hell is she
going to be the
nominee uh-uh won't
happen she's always been trying to run
for vice president and she's [__] that
up she won't be vice president rad
damama dingdong if anyone's got a shance
chance it's him the ve the ve rad dama
dingdong and the reason why he's a prime
candidate to be
to be the vice president is because he
lies like Trump lies it's
perfect it's perfect and he and he sells
Trump better than Trump sells Trump if
you want to know the honest truth I mean
really he does I mean V's not out there
like look I know he quoted Hitler from
Mom but Hitler said it a little
different that's not what radam dingdong
is not making that
case he's just like look
there are poisoning the blood of the
country like see look at me look at me
my family's immigrants and we poison the
blood so now I'm running for vice
president on the poisoning blood
ticket it's not supposed to make sense
none of this is supposed to make
sense fascism doesn't make sense
folks I don't know if you know
that but it's going to be one hell of a
year I'm excited I'm excited to take
this ride in this election with
you cuz y'all y'all are some feisty
[__] oh yeah oh yeah y you're
some feisty [__] that's what I
love about the [__] him fam that's what
I love about him and you know looking
back on this year and
reflecting on this
year d has been nothing better for this
show than the [__] him fam and and you
guys the [__] them fam I didn't come up
with that
name you guys branded yourselves that
almost three years ago that's right I've
been doing this for three [__] years
holy
[__] what's one more right let's go out
and kick some ass and take some names
[__] them fam cuz it's you
guys it really is you know I I say all
the time I've only got one microphone
you've you've got thousands of
microphones thousands of them
thousands and maybe tens of thousands
soon maybe hundreds of thousands soon
just got to get all the feisty
[__] gathered up in one spot
it's all we got to do just got to get
them all gathered up in one spot yell
and [__] scream at the top of our
lungs and they will not be able to
ignore us
they
won't trust
me they know who you
are [__] they're watching right
now I I know I I know for sure there
ain't no [__] way that there ain't
MSNBC producers watching this [__] on
the daily like it's their
assignment so that they know what the
[__] oh [__] this this is what we're
going to say in four weeks is what T
saying today he's saying Nikki Haley
ain't got a shot in Hell he's saying
that that's what he's saying he's saying
he's saying that donda santis was
getting the same money that Nikki
Haley's getting now and he [__]
flopped so evidence of Nicki Haley
getting [__] big money donors in the
Republican party is no [__]
indication that she's going to win at
all oh my God that's what they're going
to be
saying end of January beginning of
February when Donald Trump has three
[__] primaries under his belt and
we're going into South Carolina and
Nikki Haley has to win South Carolina
and she's going to [__]
lose that's what they're gonna say
that's what they're gonna say that's why
they're propping Nikki Haley up because
that's the only chance they got to beat
Trump and the media's like well if we
just convince
people if we just if we just say it out
loud then they'll believe
us the media has lost their way
commentators in this country have lost
their [__] way they've lost their way
and we're going to get them back on
track I promise you that next year we're
going to yell and scream as loud as we
possibly can and we're going to get them
back on track trust me it's going to
happen I know it I'm confident they know
who we are they know the power that we
have and the the power that we have is
not that we have to [__] we don't we
don't have to plate to what the [__] is
trending on Twitter or on social media
we don't give a [__] about that we don't
give a [__] about that we give a [__]
about the truth we give a [__] about
what real real [__] average Americans
want in this country that's what the
[__] the [__] fam kids is [__] about
that's why we're so visceral about it
yeah we're willing to use the word [__]
who cares yeah I'm gonna say the word
[__] as many times as it takes to save
our democracy I don't give a
[__] and that's what we're going to go
into 2024
doing we're going to save this [__] if
we have to just throw it on our backs
and carry it the entire way to November
we're going to do
it and I'm happy to have you here with
me to do that I really
am it's going to be it's it's going to
be a wild year and we don't even we
don't even know the half of it
yet like we don't know the half of it
like who knows when they're going to
reschedule the March 4th trial who knows
it could be like June it could be July
it could be right during the convention
think about that now everyone wants this
try to kick off in March well who gives
a [__] about March how exciting would it
be that Donald Trump can't go to the
Republican National Convention because
he's got a show up for his criminal
trial in
DC CA chuin ain't gonna give a [__] if
he's got the Republican National
Convention to go to he ain't she ain't
going to give a [__] she's going to be
like I don't give a [__] what you got to
do you're going to be here [__] you're
on trial [__] how awesome would
that be everyone's everyone's so excited
about March who gives a [__] about
March I mean here's another one what if
what what if she schedules it for
October the October surprise right like
all of a sudden this evidence just
starts coming out in [__] court right
before everyone goes and votes and he
can't do [__] about
it h again these these [__] liberal
commentators out there these people
lying to you and feeding you this
misinformation about the 14th Amendment
about the [__] trial in March all
this nonsense that they keep feeding you
and bullshitting you because they want
to make you feel good because they want
your click they want your like they want
you to go [__] follow them on on this
social media or want want you to pay
them on patreon because they got smart
brains
they're filling you full of a bunch of
[__] and I and I know I I know I got a
patreon and all that [__] but I I'm not
here to [__] [__]
you I'm not here to give you some
[__] about Lauren bobert moving
districts because it's some kind of move
for the
Republicans to make sure they keep the
house that's the last person on Earth
that anyone would want in the Colorado's
fourth district running in a primary to
make sure Republicans keep that
seat she's a [__] idiot and they know
she's a [__] idiot she barely won
last time by less than 500 votes and
Adam Frisk is out raising her and the
only reason why Lauren board is gonna go
suck the juice out of Colorado's forth
is because Donald Trump said
so
period Donald Trump said so so and
you're going to see it in the weeks to
come he's going to endorse
her
guaranteed he's going to endorse
her because they can't
win they can't win in the third with
her they can't they
won't but he needs her crazy ass [__]
in Congress when he's on trial and when
he's losing so she'll say crazy ass lies
in our [__] government's
house our
government it's
ours so I'm glad kin Buck retired [__]
him [__] Ken
Buck because this gives a huge
opportunity not only for Democrats to
win Colorado's
third but to make sure they win the
fourth too [__] maybe that's a good idea
maybe they should make her the [__]
nominee and a Democrat can beat her ass
in Colorado's
fourth how sweet would it be to pick up
two seats in Colorado now that that is a
Colorado ballot story that I'll get
behind do you see the difference do you
see the difference in someone telling
you oh man Colorado Supreme Court
totally asked the Supreme Court to take
Trump off the ballot and they're not
going to do that and we're going to talk
about
it waste all of our energy and all of
our time and all our effort when really
we could be wasting our time and effort
on winning the third and the fourth
district that's the B hey hey that's the
ballot that
matters you see what I'm talking about
prime example right there right
there how these stupid [__] idiots
out there get you distracted from the
[__]
prize the prize who gives a [__] who's
on the ballot let's go [__] slam dunk
these fascist that's the
point you you get to get rid of them and
the ballot is the way that you get rid
of them not the
courts
dummy w w
it's going to be a great 2024 right here
on the Tony Michaels podcast antifa
Central we have an antifa meeting for
two full hours every single day here on
the Tony Michaels podcast noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Facebook
twitch and now on Instagram oh by the
way I might ask you guys because I took
I didn't I don't broadcast to Twitter
anymore right but now the Twitter
Twitter comments can come
through and I can pull the Twitter
comments up on the
screen which I'm just saying I'm just
saying that that could have mass
potential of a lot of [__] dumb blue
check marks that we could pull up on the
screen and [__] with them during our
antifa meeting our 2hour antifa meeting
every single weekday so I'm asking you
should I
broadcast on Twitter again I don't know
we'll think about it don't go anywhere
don't don't leave stick around we'll be
right back we're going to shoot this
[__] when we come back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out down the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
Hardon blanket I've got you covered
paron blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup
Parton blanket will protect you too
paron blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome to the antifa corporate
headquarters
here at e Tony Michaels podcast that's
where we broadcast from the antia
corporate headquarters that's
right
that's where we broadcast live every
single weekday new Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on Facebook YouTube twitch and
Instagram we broadcast from here the
antifa corporate headquarters that's
right that's right outside the building
here
why
not I mean it'll get the [__] Shard
Army all [__] unies in a bundle you
know what I mean maybe maybe we'll just
start
um maybe we'll just start making that a
thing where we broadcast broadcast from
the antifa corporate
headquarters here in Kami Falls Missouri
that's where I live I live in Kami Falls
Miss
Missouri that's where the um antifa
corporate headquarters
is oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy so
Grandpa Hitler is
out quoting
mom in English not in German because
Hitler said it different he said it in
German it it is written in German
originally he makes a good point you
know what I mean I mean how can I
[__] refute him he makes a good point
Hitler did say it a little different
Hitler spoke German it's the
thing but now we have Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley talking about slavery well not
talking about slavery kind of you know
what I mean like she wants to be like
stat
rats it's funny because people think
that um Nikki Haley is going to beat
Donald Trump is really stupid because
she's worse at reading a room than Ronda
santz uh speaking of Ronda Sanz I do
want to show you one clip of that
irrelevant Florida fascist you know
what's good about Ronda santz running is
that he's not in Florida trying to
oppress people you know what I mean so I
mean I think I think it's going to be
really sad when Ronda santz actually
drops out of the race because now he's
going to get to go back to Florida and
try to oppress he's going to start
oppressing people there again as opposed
to running around the country talking
about how he wants to oppress people if
he never becomes president because he
never
will oh [__] putting fingers Ron oh poop
M
Ron he can't read a room and neither can
Nikki Haley they try really
hard they try really hard to um to read
a room what do you like you can see
slavery you can see
it when they're trying to do
it
[Music]
but it doesn't work very
well and the reason why it doesn't work
very well is because they're not Trump
they're not the cult
leader the cult's not going to blindly
follow Ronda santis that was the problem
like literally if you go look at Ronda
santis supporters on Twitter that's all
they [__] talk about that's all they
tweet about like the biggest [__]
Ronda santz supporters and they've got a
pretty good army built online of Ronda
santz supporters that's all they talk
about is how Donald Trump is the cult
leader and maanga is a cult that's all
they say over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and what what
is glaringly obvious is that they didn't
learn from the mistakes of the
left is that trying to make them change
the cult change their minds is not going
to work it's not going to work you're
not going to change the minds of these
people like that lady we saw yesterday
in the video where she's talking about
you know all kinds of crazy ass [__] she
not blinking one bit she's all [__]
hopped up on political orgasms you know
what I mean oh and she just can't oh man
she's
[__] she's ready she's ready to say
some crazy [__] off her Facebook page
you know what I mean you're not going to
convince those people
like it it you're not going to like
stand there and say something then go oh
yeah you know what you're right
everything that I've been saying
everything that I've been reading on
Facebook all of it's all [__] wrong
like they're not going to do that
overnight it's going to take a little
bit to get them in a position I mean
hell I'm going to show you a picture
today of of the insurrectionist grandma
Yeah there's a there's an
insurrectionist grandma and she's
bitching pissing and moaning that she
was is breaking windows and telling
people which Windows to go in and
guiding them through the capital to hang
Mike Pence and she got she got some like
51 months in a federal prison for it and
she's [__]
pissed how dare they give
me prison time for my
crimes that lady isn't even
convinced and she's sitting there
whining bitching pissing and moaning
about how she's gonna have to pay for
the [__] decisions that she
made listen I have paid for decisions
I've made before you guys know this I
have a history they doxed me online they
thought it was really cool as if I was
ashamed of my past that I've been to
lenworth it's not a place that anyone
wants to go it's not I don't care if
you're in the camp or the big house it's
not a place people want to go and really
honestly it it [__] with your psyche
because really truly when you go to a
prison they are taking away what you
value most which is your freedom and
honestly it's one of the reasons why
most people who have been the prison
value Freedom almost more than anything
else like
anything like you're you have nothing
you have nothing if you don't have your
freedom
let me let me describe to you a little
bit let me describe to you just just a
little bit about
how [__] awful it is to have your
freedom taken
away you have a little chair and you got
a little bitty bed okay you got about
three square feet and you got a metal
box to keep all your [__] in and it
ain't that big and you got to keep
everything in it your clothes your
food your toilet trees everything has to
fit in that [__] metal box okay
that's it that's all you got you just
got this little space it's not very big
and you got to share it with another
[__] most of the time kicker is
they can come and go through your [__]
and take all your stuff all of it they
can take all your [__] the only thing
they can't take is your [__] mail
that's it they can't take your
mail they can take it
all just take it from you and they just
toss in the trash I'm not [__] you
just throw it in the trash they'll take
your mattress and toss that [__] in the
trash ah it's yeah it's got a cut on it
it's not you know it's not appropriate
so throw it
away I'm telling you it's not fun to
have your [__] Freedom stripped from
you and really
isn't especially when you actually did
something to have your freedom taken
away from you whether you agree with it
or not cuz most people most people go to
prison listen most people go to prison
are like no I didn't do that thing or
I'm innocent there's a few there's a few
that are like no I did that
[__] I did it yeah I mean maybe I should
have got as much time as I got but I did
that
[__] but having your freedom stripped is
no [__] fun at all and again anyone
who has had that H actually have it
happened to him like
physically you can't move you can't go
anywhere they count you like cattle they
count you several times a day you got to
stand by your bed and they [__] count
you or in your cell and they count you 1
2 3 four five six 6
okay that's what they want for all of us
you know that
right you know that's why y' and scream
every [__] day
it's the reason why I'm so [__]
passionate about
this I've been counted like
cattle and honestly if if I if if I
wasn't white and a man I would have done
much more time than I ever did way
more I was I was I was locked up with
guys that had
decades decades for non-violent
[__] they were black they were Mexican
it's the
truth but having your freedom is no
[__] walk in the
park and they're doing it to women right
now doing it to women right now they're
doing it to the lgbtq community right
now it's why it pisses me off so [__]
much I get so [__] pissed off when I
watch a bunch of [__] Nazis get
elected into power over some stupid
[__]
slogan like make America great again and
then go to try to take people's [__]
freedom and their Liberty
away it pisses me
off and I'm not gonna put up with it I
won't I'm not I'm not going to shut up
about it for
sure and that is the
point that we need to be showing you
that hey they they want to be able to
come in your house and take your [__]
it's what they want they want to be to
tell you where you can and can't
live they're going to start doing that
[__] they're going to tell you what
property you can and can't own they're
going to start doing that [__] they're
going to tell you what clothes you can
wear and what you can't they're going to
start doing that [__] they've already
started that what do you think the drag
queen things
are hey shz hey hey Putin puppet I don't
know how much he's paying you to post
this
[__] but you are in the wrong spot to
think that we're
scared
oh oh yeah they're running Running
Scared yeah I'm Running Scared Jaz so
much so that I I I quit doing my
show the [__] out of
here oh
loser keep keep commenting though buddy
keep going you're really um making sure
that the the Facebook Chat is highly
engaged people like to engage in you all
right let's do this let's shoot the [__]
for a bit you guys know what shoot the
[__] is you guys know what shoot the
[__] is you can ask any question you
want I may or may not answer it here in
the chat because I seen a couple
questions what' you go to prison for
what'd you go to prison it's a long
story it's a long story it's a long
story um green um pug and Cactus here
says Shaz loves you Tony well he's paid
to love me he's paid to love me I mean I
wish I wish it was like genuine and you
know
unconditional I don't I don't think he
is I don't think he is I don't think
it's unconditional it's conditional on
him getting baed um because he didn't
come over to YouTube he didn't come over
to YouTube when I got banned from
Facebook I was really upset I thought he
did love
me someone on Twitch says score Monger
says so Shaz is a filthy [__] I don't
know I don't know if he dresses up as a
filthy [__] in his spare time I have no
idea honestly I don't care really
frankly Shaz you should be doing that
you should dress up as a as Putin's um
filthy [__] all right ask some
questions ask some questions ask some
questions I'll answer them and shoot the
[__] time that's right we're going to do
this because it's the end of the
year uh scream says do you watch Dusty
Smith I don't I don't know I don't know
who Dusty Smith is is that um some kind
of political
commentator is that is that who Dusty
Smith is I have no idea I mean may maybe
I have maybe I have seen some stuff
um oh is it oh is it the guy who runs
around with the um uh
um I I don't remember I
I I don't remember I I maybe I've seen
his stuff before maybe I've seen I think
I haven't seen his stuff before I think
people s this stuff before
but even big sta fan says who never
heard of them
yeah I don't know I mean that's that's
the challenge right so that that's what
I was trying to say in the beginning is
you got a lot of these um the the
mainstream media right um the people
that are actually supposed to be doing
like journalism um and they're not doing
journalism they're trying they're trying
to construct narrative which they're
horrible at it they're horrible at
constructing narrative because they
still
think that they can they can actually sh
narrative in this country and they don't
understand how the internet works
apparently I guess but you know that's
um that's neither here nor there um but
then you have the people who try to copy
who try to copy um mainstream media CU
they like no no we're we're different
we're different but we're the same like
we we copy it almost exactly because we
want to be them and and it the problem
is is that you you shouldn't you
shouldn't be trying to be them that's
the problem like with MSNBC CNN some of
these places they if you're trying to be
them then you're them and they suck like
that's the whole point that's why
they're always six eight weeks
behind you know like I was saying six
weeks from now on MSNBC they're going to
be Joe scarber is going to be saying
Nikki Haley doesn't have a shot she's
done
and of course you know they're not going
to say well this guy on YouTube this
[__] crazy ass [__] on
YouTube who yells and screams and says
the FW all the time into a microphone
they're not gonna they're not going to
say well that's he was on oh man that's
the real he was on to it because then
they'll just come watch me like they
they won't have to you won't have to
watch MSNBC
anymore you won't have to watch MSNBC
anymore
uh Williams says what are your thoughts
on Richard o Jetta I've had I've had the
major on the show I I think he has his
place he's got the different style than
me um his show isn't exactly like mine
that's that's the difference so but I I
think I think o jetta's got good
commentary he uses types of language
that should be used he used types of
narratives that should be used so
I think major is is a good player in the
commentary
game now I mean if I had to give him
some criticism I would say get the hell
off tyt even if it's Rebel
HQ but I mean I would tell him that to
his face because tyt is [__] I wouldn't
I wouldn't want to be associated with
that in any way shape or
form if I could help
it if I could help it so Christine says
how about a yakety
schacky you want a yakety schacky
t-shirt all right we could probably make
that happen yakety
schacky ramama damama
dingdong ah just make this [__] up um
let's
see Jen asks can we please have the
short story of why you went to prison I
committed uh what the federal government
thought was a crime there's the short
story federal government thought that I
committed a crime uh kayn Patterson asks
Tony Michaels who do you think will be
the best Biden surrogate in 2024 um
Trump trump will be the best Biden
surrogate that that that is why I'm not
terrified of that [__] that's
why I'm not scared that's why I actually
deep down inside I want him on the
ballot because we need to vote him gone
again because he hasn't gone way after
the last time we said go get the [__]
out of here right get the [__] out of
here and we we need to keep telling
these [__] fascists to [__] off until
they [__] off for
good and the best way to do it is the
ballot it's not polls it's not it's it's
it's not trying to [__] win an
argument on Twitter or get something
trending that's not how you win this AR
that's not how you get them to crawl
back underneath their [__] rocks
how you do it is make sure that they
don't have the reins of power which is
our governments mints like plural the
federal government state governments
County governments school
boards County commissions Road districts
okay it all [__] matters it all
matters because they take any
opportunity they can to [__] pile
their fascism into your [__]
communities so Trump will be the best
Biden surrogate in 2024 cuz Biden's
going to go yeah I'm old but he wants to
be Hitler I mean what what better
surrogate or do you get really
honestly
um Melanie says Tony ple please keep
calling out Joe Rogan oh well I mean
yeah sure I I again I would go on Joe's
show he wouldn't have me on
though I doubt it I doubt would there
may come a day though that I get invited
and if I got invited I would probably go
I would probably go and I would
probably I would probably I would
probably go and in just to intentionally
eat his
lunch so there is that so I mean if you
want to campaign for that sure go for
it what other questions do we have
[Music]
here is it possible to get 60 Democrats
as senators in
2024 are they I don't think we're going
to get
um depending on how far Grandpa Hitler
goes with his rhetoric U I believe Colin
alred has a really good chance in Texas
believe it or not and I think Lucas C if
he becomes the nominee in Missouri I
think he has a really good chance
against Holly and the reason why I say
how far Trump goes with his rhetoric is
because that's going to matter folks
it's going to be it's going to matter in
the in real life everyday talk when
people are yapping to each other talking
about politics this and that when we get
into you know the dog days of summer
next year uh the Trump trials are coming
for the DC Trump because I I I I I
suspect that chuin when she moves this
thing from March it's probably going to
be June July um possibly August or
September is where she's going to move
it you you just think about how federal
court court cases work and the timing of
them and she's not going to move it
because she's like I want it to be this
date it's because they have a docket
already like they have a schedule
already made it's not like in DC there's
the only thing they're [__] trying
and the only case they're hearing in DC
is Trump's criminal
case so chuin can't schedule something
on top of something that's already in
that courtroom if that makes sense it's
not possible right that's just not how
scheduled work that that's why that's
why you're when they do when she does
reschedule the March War trial you're
going to have [__] Bon heads yelling
and screaming about oh it's Injustice
and it's going to be you know on one
side and the other and they're going to
be saying stupid [__] to try to make you
feel good which is going to be really
dumb when they could just tell you the
truth and say hey the reason why it's
[__] in September what whatever date
that Chuck ins sets it is because
there's a schedule already there in
those courtrooms in that Courthouse like
she has to find a spot where she can
actually hold the trial physically so
but um back to your question Democrats
60 in the Senate the reason why that's
important in the Dog Days uh depending
on how U Hitler likee Grandpa's rhetoric
is you're going to have you're going to
see like Ted Cruz and Josh Holly and
some of these other Senators have to
fend that [__] and that's where it's
going to get mixed right it's going to
get really messy because they're going
to have to try to defend that [__] but
yet not defend it um and they're going
to turn away voters they're not going to
attract voters and the reason why is
because you're from from from both
angles okay so uh imagine this imagine
Donald Trump is saying yes I I he just
leans into it which that's what he's
going to do that's what he does with
every stupid thing that he says and does
is he leans into it really dumb it's
dumb but he doesn't so he's going to
lean into the dictator thing and the
whole I read from m c and Hitler said it
in German but I say it in English so
he's gonna he's going to lean into that
the dict taster
thing and Ted
Cruz in Texas is g to have to be in one
room with a bunch of trump supporters
who want him to be a dictator and a
bunch of people who want to vote for Ted
Cruz but don't want Trump as a dictator
they're Republicans but they don't want
that dictator [__] they're tired of that
[__] right their [__] party is at
Civil War not the country they keep
saying oh the country's at Civil War
well they think it's at Civil War
because they're at civil war with
themselves and it's over
authoritarianism in their
party again it's the reason why Lauren
Bower is going to go try to [__] suck
the juice out of Colorado's
forth again I don't know I'm sure beetle
juu is playing somewhere in Colorado and
not house she could she could [__]
put it on a VHS TV somewhere and she
could watch it and I'm just saying she
likes Beetlejuice that's all I'm saying
that's all I'm saying but people like T
Cruz and Josh Holly are going to have to
defend that
rhetoric and it's going to fracture
their
support in their
race so I mean I don't think Democrats
will get to 60 but if they're picking up
seats like Missouri and Texas which I
think is possible depending on how crazy
their Hitler rhetoric gets but I don't
think we get the 60 but the the the the
the main thing is is that we actually
have the majority in the Senate and the
house and we have Hakeem Jeff as the
speaker of the house that's
important um George Jefferson says do
you ever do a meet and greet I'd like to
meet you hey George no I've never done a
meet and greet I mean I guess I could
somewhere but I don't know know how many
people would show
up I'm really I'm really I'm I this is
all a filter I'm not this good-look and
real
life H do you have a plan to organize
your fans in 2024 yeah we're gonna
[__] create the narrative we're going
to throw the narrative on our backs and
carry it up the
hill we're GNA have a lot of antifa
meetings at the antifa headquarters
every single week day two full hours
we're going to have antifa meetings
every [__] weekday Monday through
Friday the entire year that's what we're
going to
do let's see what other questions we
got um Patrick asked why hasn't anyone
talked about the guy who ran into Biden
Secret Service about two weeks ago and
never seen anything yeah there was like
a car accident or something I don't I
don't know if there was anything
nefarious about that or not I I saw I
saw something about it and
the part that was really [__] wild is
that Biden was kind of standing there
when it happened you know what I mean
like he was walking out of the building
trying to get into the motorcade and
then someone like crashed into one of
the one of the SUVs but I I don't think
it actually got too close to the
president
um uh oh oh small rat is queuing me in
here from the laboratory he says
DUI DUI is possibly what it was so so
it's just crazy Dr drivers
you crazy drunk
drivers you remember that from Back to
the
Future um left-handed Jedi says Tony do
you think Trump or Mago will try to
resurrect Charles Lindberg as an
American
hero uh I see I I see what you're doing
there I see what you're doing on left
handed Jedi H for people who don't know
Charles Lindberg was actually uh the
American German who who um would go
around talking about America first and
American Nazism and they would use they
would use uh George
Washington as like their their fascist
Idol because at the time and even now
you know George Washington he's the
father of our country you know he's the
first president of the United States if
you're not up the speed on History um so
they they would use George
Washington uh to as kind of like their
their symbol of American fascism just
like they use Trump now as their symbol
of American fascism so and they did it
to Reagan too I've told you for a long
time that that that the Republican party
has been a cult for many many decades
they just never really had their cult
leader yet
so but yeah they I mean they might start
talking about it it's possible in the
deep dark uh right-wing web they do
idolize Charles Lindberg uh to do you
think Trump smells like [__] yes
absolutely um like Adam ker says it's
something to behold so me and Cliff
talked about this
yesterday and I would imagine that [__]
is not the only scent that permeates off
that [__] fat puke you know what I
mean like it is [__] like is probably
the main the main scent but I would say
other stenches would be like um Big Mac
fop sweat Aquanet I would imagine like I
said yesterday I bet the guy uses a
shitload of Axe Body Spray you ever met
one of these guys have you ever met and
and listen if you use Axe Body Spray a
lot in the uh in the chat yes I'm making
fun of you 100% I'm making fun of
you cuz it [__] stinks man I mean a
little a little bit of it isn't bad but
a lot of Axe Body Spray is
horrible stop using so much of that [__]
so I'd imagine that he's he's kind
because he probably doesn't use really
expensive good cologne right like like
someone could probably you know if they
had a certain body odor they could put
on a good anti-perspirant and probably
combined with a really good cologne um
to kind of cover whatever Natural Body
cuz you know some people have natural
body odor that other people don't have
everyone smells a little different right
I don't know if you went around smelling
people's butt cracks but they all smell
a little different okay
so you know I can understand if someone
needs a little assistance and not
smelling so goddamn repugnant but you
know that this guy you know that this
guy piles [__] on cuz he's got to have
the scent of [__] of musty clothes I
don't know if you've ever seen his
[__] suits they look all wrinkly and
[__] they they literally when when he's
standing before he goes on stage they're
steaming his suit can you imagine having
to be that close to that stink ass
[__] and then putting hot steam
in
him oh my God you talk about like a
[__] Barnyard you know what I'm
saying God damn it's just got to be
horrible and again it's all kinds of
different [__] scents you yeah you
got again you got Aquanet you got ax
body spray you got the caked on makeup
everywhere um I'm sure I'm sure that the
guy uses Icy Hot on everything you know
what I mean ointments and and I
uh Icy
Hot on everything probably and then and
then think about the the the sweat
soaked girdle that he wears you know
what I'm saying like he wears that
girdle all the time and I'm sure they
don't wash those [__] and he
probably has some kind of [__] weird
thing where it has to be that one you
know I got to wear that that's my lucky
girdle you know what I mean oh yeah he
wears a girdle 100% he wears a girdle
that's probably why he can't hold his
[__] [__] in anymore is cuz he's
[__] winched his guts down so much
and he eats fried [__] chicken and
Big Macs all the time and he definitely
wears a girdle because if you've ever
seen him like in the pictures where he's
at Mar Lago golfing and he's like in the
khakis and the [__] the I I used to
be president I want to be president
again but I never will t-shirt you know
what I'm talking about he's got the fake
presidential seal and it says Donald
Trump never will be president again I
think it says something like that on
there um but he just you can tell it's
all hanging out right he ain't got the
girdle on for for Gulf he ain't got a
gulf
girdle so that girdle's got a stin it's
got a
stin so yeah I think he does probably
smell like [__] but there's a lot of
other scents that he smells
like Mel says how is an insurrectionist
allowed to run for president
why CU he's not convicted of
insurrection he's not he's not charged
with it either so and and I
mean I've been critical of Jack Smith
lately which we should start getting
critical of Jack Smith we should start
doing that he needs to start [__]
doing superseding indictments Eastman
Clark Giuliani [__] Mike Flynn mark
Meadows they need to start doing
superseding indictments on these members
of Congress and these members in the
Senate they had anything to do with this
which we know they
did they need to stop focusing on
[__] not getting Trump elected let us
handle that and they do their [__]
jobs we will do our job of democracy and
vote these [__] out you do your
job and prosecute these some [__] so
I hope that answers the question I don't
think it does
but
maybe oh let see what else do we get
what else got someone says Molly says I
love o Jetta yeah sure that's cool big
step fan says I won't quit Lawrence o'
Donald his show is good his show is good
I mean I've watched Lawrence odonald I
haven't watched him in a long time um
and I I haven't watched Rachel in a long
time um I I think I think the person the
producer that actually comes and listens
here is um I don't think it's a morning
Joe producer I think it's I think it's
Joy Reed
and and I know and I know Trump's
campaign follows this [__] too U because
Laura lomer follows me so she's she's on
I'm I'm on her radar um so it's just
really weird but it's how it goes I wish
she I wish she would I wish she would
out me you know she's known for lummer
you got lered okay lummer me lummer
let's do that let's get into a back and
forth I'd love to battle lumor from the
antia anti corporate
headquarters and question do I think
that the six Nazis on the Supreme Court
will rule that Trump has has immunity no
I don't think they'll rule that he has
immunity um but it has to work in the
natural the natural progress of appeals
courts because Jack Smith actually got
his motion dunked in the trash because
the Supreme Court's like you know get to
do that you got to go through the
process of appeals we're not just going
to hear your case you got to go through
the process we don't give a [__] if you
don't want the trial delayed that isn't
how it works that isn't normal process
because if you read the motion Jack
Smith is desperately trying to get the
Supreme Court to make these decisions so
that he can do the trial on March 4th
which he knows if they don't make these
decisions he's not going to get to do
that's why anyone telling you that the
trial is going to start on March 4th is
[__] lying to you if they say that
they're [__] lying to you okay
they're [__] lying to
you um but I I don't think I don't think
think I don't think the Supreme Court is
going to say I don't think they're going
to rule and it's probably going to be 81
or 72 decision um on that that would be
my guess is that um they won't say that
he has presidential immunity I don't
think it will I think it's a really a
really dumb question that we ask our
Supreme Court this um we had to ask him
kind of the same question during Nixon
it's it was a little different
circumstance because Nixon was just like
trying to hide stuff of crimes that he
committed and Trump was trying to coup
so it's a little different I don't you
think that um just a question don't you
think that us as a country kind of
should apologize to H Richard Nixon's
ghost at this point like really we like
that [__] the worst president of
all time the most crooked son of a [__]
ever like we had no
idea no
clue how corrupt and crooked it could
get and how ridiculous it could be with
these ninka poop
Nazis we just totally underestimated the
crime that these people would
commit maybe we do owe him an apology I
don't know but I don't think the Supreme
Court's going to rule in Trump's favor
on this immunity thing I don't think so
now they're going to rule in his favor
on the ballot so he will win that one
now what wait I I do want to say one
other thing about this because it is
possible because it is a question before
The Supreme Court and these [__]
chuckleheads are [__] right I mean
they are [__] the especially the
three that he appointed they're [__]
[__] what do you want from me they
overturned roie Wade they took away
rights from people what do you want from
me they're
fascist but I do want to say that a lot
of people on the left um are saying that
the reason why they won't is because as
soon as they rule that he has
presidential immunity then Joe Biden is
going to be president forever which is a
bunch of [__] because that all
hinges on Joe Biden trying to commit a
coup are any president after him trying
to commit a coup right and really
honestly it's going to be a long time
before we have another president try to
commit a
coup I know that sounds wild right
because we just had one um but that's
why is because we're going to [__]
that [__] scent if someone even has
the stench of cing you're gone [__] and
we're really going to keep our eyes all
[__] watching uh from the antifa
headquarters here on the Republican
party because they're the ones that are
likely to C at least in this
timeline so um Yogi ask do you think the
santis will ever withdraw from the race
or do you think his ego well I mean he's
going to have to withdraw
eventually and the reason why is because
no one's going to give him money so he's
not going to actually be able to
campaign like it takes money to campaign
you can't just you know it's not free so
he won't be able to go to states he
won't be able to go campaign for
primaries uh he'll be losing them badly
so they'll pull all the money because
anyone giving money to Ronda Sanz when
he clearly is going to lose is a [__]
idiot now I don't even know why they're
still giving him money that's one of the
reasons why they switched to Nikki Haley
and this idea that somehow she's going
to be able to sell their money in the
primary is really [__] dumb it's
really stupid
and anyone telling you that is just as
dumb
um let's see what else do we got
here Carter says tyt hates America I
agree they're not in it for America
they're not in it for the Democracy it's
all a big fat grift it's all big fat
grift which hey I'm going to grip here
in a little bit I promise I'll grift
here in a little
bit uh we got to keep the show going
somehow I run off your support this
microphone stays powered on against
fascism because of you your support
either on patreon or sending in um shots
um any donations yeah that's right send
in some money buying merch um that's how
this microphone stays powered and you
coming here every single day to our our
daily antifa meetings at the antifa
headquarters here in commi Falls
Missouri oh we should build a whole
story around this rant do you have do
you have a map of Kami Falls Missouri
can you get me a map of um commi Falls
Missouri so we can show the people okay
good all right let's see
um did it skip
back that's the first time I've had the
mute for a call today how do you like
that my cough is almost gone I'm still
kind of stuffy
but have I ever written a book I've read
books not written one I mean I write
stuff every day you should see my
tweets you should see my
tweets I like the verbal form of
creation if you want to know the honest
truth um so I guess some people could
take my transcripts and probably make
them into a book might be a little
difficult cuz it's kind of like all over
the place SP
but they could probably do
it but I mean I should write a book
probably maybe I will one of these
days Scott says I'm psyched that you use
this machine kills fascist you're in
good company with Woody Guthrie can you
mention him he was a fighter yes he was
a fighter he and a lot of people thought
he was a communist he was actually not a
a card carrying commi like we are here
at the antifa corporate head quarters in
commi Falls
Missouri it is it's um um what's the
address uh it's probably like um
666 um punch a Nazi Lane something like
that um is the address I don't know
someone will come up with this [__]
probably in the Discord of what the
address here is here at at the antifa
headquarters and Kami Kami Falls
Missouri um but yes Woody got three was
a great great
great um musician and he wrote a lot of
protest songs so and um it's funny
because this land is your land is a
fantastic song and a lot of people um
who were like I hate communism [__]
commies [__] the laugh [__] liberals
and they sing this land is your land and
they have no idea they have no idea it's
kind of like when they play Bruce
Springsteen's Born in the USA born in
the
USA and they don't know what the lyrics
are in that song like if they just
looked at the lyrics they wouldn't play
that [__] song Thinking then it's
patriotic same with a YMCA like Donald
Trump's like
YMCA y if they actually [__] figured
out what the lyrics of that song mean
they wouldn't play that [__] [__]
bigots but you know that's how it
goes uh Dr huan 1014 wait jail
or
prison lenworth is a
prison lenworth is a I mean you know
it's a jail too I mean they got jail
cells
but they're already coming up with
addresses of where the u n the corporate
headquarters is on on Discord speaking
of that you should go to Discord that's
right I'm going to promote the Discord
here really quick uh you guys should
definitely go over to the Discord let's
see if I can get the link here now do
you guys have the
link it's been a while since I where
where do I got the link here I got the
link here somewhere somewhere here I got
the link hang on it's been a while since
I've had it up here um there it is I'll
put the I'll put the link in the uh in
the chat here so you guys can go join
the Discord and then you guys can uh
participate in like the in the in the
um making sure we get the right address
I mean one listen we want the correct
return address uh when we send you your
your laminated antifa membership card
from the antifa headquarters so we want
the
correct we want the correct return
address
so you guys are asking all kinds of
questions now you're like prison prison
what yeah it's a thing it's funny
because the troll Farm I think it was
last year or year before they thought it
was going to be they were going to get
me and they were going to get me to shut
up by telling the truth I don't know
they thought I wouldn't tell the truth I
guess I'm not really sure um but they
were even like going and robbing
pictures of my kids and posting it on
Twitter to try to get me to apologize to
some [__] some [__] Nazi [__] that
I will not apologize to ever ever
ever um and they were they were trying
to get me to apologize and they were
threatening to dox me and I said dox me
[__] and they did um but I mean I I
told the audience I talk about it so but
it's but listen this show is not about
me that's why I don't talk about a lot
of that stuff in General on this show
because the show is not about me so a
lot of people want to make their shows
about
them and that's not what the show's
about but I appreciate you guys showing
interest I really do I think you guys um
it's happening uh
let's see what else do we got here we
got some more questions we're just going
to shoot this [__] I think we should
shoot I'm going to show you this Nikki
Haley U
clip I have a couple other couple other
um ones that um Karen asked were you in
the service no I I wasn't in the
military I was not in the military I
have a lot of of friends and my younger
brother's friends that went to the
military after 911 um but I was I was
just getting out of school at 9911 and I
went to college and then I started a
family and started working and so I
never was in the service um but I I
actually thank a lot of people who went
to the service during that time and the
reason why is because I got to stay here
with and raise my family and work and
that sort of thing so let's see what
else do we got what other questions we
got you guys can keep asking them here
um uh do you think people are afraid kot
will be president no I don't think that
no I mean
she's a horrible politician as far as
like retail politics it's one reason why
um she didn't last in the Democratic
Primary in uh uh in 2020 um because she
she doesn't she doesn't have the retail
politics that others have um but she's
really [__] smart and a lot of people
don't like that she's a prosecutor it's
actually one of the things I don't like
about her that she was a prose I don't
like prosecutors in general generally
speaking um
but but I I don't think they're scared
that Kamas would be the president
because that's how it works they voted
for her once um she hasn't done anything
to prove that she would be dangerous or
anything she isn't running around
[__] quoting mcom saying that she
would love to be a dict taster so you
know what I
mean
um let's see what else do we got here
any other questions you got if you guys
got questions uh go
ahead says I will buy a membership card
are you talking about antifa to the
antifa corporate headquarters holy [__]
maybe we should I didn't think about
that maybe we could do that maybe we
should make a um a an official antifa
membership card now I got I got [__]
them fanny packs that and that's the
that's what it's for the [__] fanny
packs let me show you these [__]
fanny packs here Robin um they're
designed here's the grift part of the
show and they're
designed to put your antifa membership
card in that's the that's the whole
point of the design of the [__] fanny
pack is so that you can carry around
your antifa membership card you just go
to store. thony michaels.com or go to
the Tony michaels.com if you go to the
Tony michaels.com you're going to have
to click on that my dog hates tag Cruise
link and that'll take you over to the
store that has the U has the the [__]
them fanny packs where you you can hold
your you know you can carry around your
antifa membership card you know that way
you got it
handy that way you got it
handy all what else do we
in
um let's
see sorry this chat's going pretty fast
the chat goes pretty fast here you guys
are wild in the
chat uh Regina says I don't want to know
your rap sheet and I mean you can go
look it up if you
want ba ba we says the Tony Michaels
podcast isn't about Tony Micha no it's
not about me no it's not about
me it it features me apparently it's
kind of cool actually um you know that
that is that is kind of a uh an
important thing um I know I I think it's
important
um you see a lot of other shows they
name them other things like with this
person right or this person I just think
branding branding as the person
themselves and the name Tony Michaels
itself was better that's just kind of
how I saw it now originally I wanted it
to be called the Tony Michaels show but
there was already a podcast that was
still kind of around it's not around
anymore and it was called the Tony
Michaels show but it was um is a
different guy of course um but it it was
about a totally different topic than
politics like they didn't talk about
politics I think he's a I think he's
like a professional dance instructor or
something like that I I think so anyways
I I did a little bit of research when I
when I named the show um so I just went
with the next best thing which was
podcast because everyone knows what
podcasts are I guess um but I I would
have preferred to have show but it's
podcast now so that's just it's the way
it
goes it's the way it goes let's see
here
um uh Murphy murf says did you take
Media Radio in college no um I did I did
compete in high school uh in forensic
speech and speech and debate team I was
on the speech and debate team in high
school um for many many years and I
competed in competitions I did radio as
a that's like a category uh so I did
radio then um but I've always I've
always had an interest in you know
making silly voices and stuff like that
even with my kids you know I make silly
voices with them and um so and
Performing and entertaining has always
been a thing and then I was in sales um
from the time I left high school and
until I started doing this um I was in
sales so I had to use forms of
communication uh to commun Comm unicate
with people and I would always use humor
and stuff like that um to do that so but
no I I never actually took um radio or
media in college now I was I um when I
first went to college because I'm a
two-time College Dropout that's another
thing that a lot of people like don't
say that I'm like why it's true I
dropped out of college twice okay I
thought it was ridiculous that I was
paying all that money to have someone
teach me something that I could just go
read anyways oh you put you get an
official degree to do what to sit and
talk on a
microphone what okay all right I don't
needed degree to be really good at that
um but I but I originally was
business what a waste of [__] money
that was business and then um history my
first time and the second time it was
history and
polyi um so I actually studied Civics in
college so I wasn't a Media Radio I was
a history major and polyi so actually
studied this stuff um so I mean you know
you read but you don't need to go get a
college degree to know this stuff you
really don't and I I don't mean to I
don't mean to seem like I'm [__] on
people with college degrees but maybe I
am it's kind of like when I [__] on um
when I [__] on lawyers I'm like look you
don't really um you don't need you don't
need to be smart to be a lawyer in this
country it's it's true uh
Karen says grift me Tony feels so good
that's how I'm
imagining grift me Tony feels so
good yeah we definitely we definitely
need a sound for that um right grift me
Tony it feels so good give it to me give
me the grift give it to me give it to me
give it to me I no you people are wild
this is the end it's the end of the year
did you know tomorrow tomorrow on Friday
is going to be the last show of the year
I got some sad news Gabe is g to be on
the road during the show H he's been
he's been he's been out on vacation
because he's visiting family for the
holidays that's where Gabe's been and
he's going to be on the road tomorrow so
I was I was messaging him earlier and I
was asking him if we should do bonehead
of the year tomorrow but he's not gonna
be able to do it
tomorrow because he's gonna be on the
road so he won't be able to do the bowet
of the week uh because he won't be able
to rely on his signal he could do it on
the cell phone but he won't be able to R
rely on his signal so it' be uh it would
be a [__] show um so our idea is maybe
to do the 2023 Bon Hen of the year next
Friday so to be next and really honestly
it's not a bad idea and the reason why
is cuz you've seen Lauren bobert come in
and try to really capture the boneh head
of the Year here at the very end but we
still have several days left of 2023 and
my guess is is that there's going to be
other [__] that are going to
try to take that title so maybe we
shouldn't do it tomorrow maybe what we
should do is wait until the year is
completely finished up until the [__]
the clock strikes
midnight U because you never know they
could be in that last 10 minutes we
could really get a bonehead of the year
and they're Republicans what do you want
from me I don't [__] get to decide
this stuff we just talk about it okay we
just comment on it I'm just commenting
on what the [__] they're doing I'm not
controlling what they're
doing but maybe we should do that next
year or next week in the next year it is
next year next week we should do
bonehead of the year next week what do
you guys think I think that that that
that I think that could work I think
that could work give it to me give it to
me give it to me
he's already got it you see that just
like just like that just like that the
laboratory the rat at the
laboratory it is a great addition that
we've had speaking of um recapping the
year um that is a great addition that
we've made to the Tony Michaels podcast
this year is having the laboratory and
doing the AI work that we've done all
the all the sounds and all the
background stuff that the rat does yes
thank you rat thank you rat let's see uh
he still got his Christmas costume on
his elf thank you you're still in the
Christmas spirit I see yeah yeah he
likes Christmas okay all
right I think he's wanting me to move on
to the Nikki Haley thing I got a few
more questions in the chat here man I'm
trying to I'm trying to you know enjoy
the year with the the
um the audience here let's see what else
do we have
uh Cynthia says are you going to and
Gabe going to Chicago for DNC we want to
we still want to do that um it just
depends on you know his schedule my
schedule I'd like to go that might be a
good opportunity for a meet and greet it
just it's going to cost a lot of money
because so many people are going to be
in Chicago at that time so it's going to
cost a lot of money so I might have
to grift me Tony give it to me give it
to me give it to me give it to me I
might have to do a lot of grifting give
it to me give it to me
uh you know what I mean to make that
happen but I I think it's it's still in
the cards I mean I'd love I love because
me and Gabe um that's one thing some
people still probably don't know is we
actually um we actually uh haven't met
each other in
person a lot of people think that's
crazy lot of people think that's crazy
Regina says didn't they find gab's car
yeah they did find gab's car they did
find it but he doesn't get to keep it
now because he did the whole in
insurance thing so he's got to go get a
different car he's got to go get a
different
one let's see we're going to move on to
the here in just a second we're going to
move on to the I want to show you the
Nikki Haley clip and I got a couple
other Clips I want to show you uh here
uh today in the last 30 minutes I've had
so much fun just spending the hour you
guys asking questions and us talking
about just crazy Off the Wall [__] it's
December 28th it's the end of the year I
know a lot of people are busy for the
holidays a lot of people are busy this
week probably still off work and
traveling now maybe making plans for the
New Year's holiday I want you guys all
to be safe this week and then through
the weekend and New Year's um because I
want you to come back and join us here
at the antifa head corporate
headquarters every single weekday for
our daily our daily antifa cookie
meetings that's right we have cookies
here
um there's someone eating fresh baked
cookies out there I'm sure in the
audience
right let's see what what else do we
have
here um Henry says Tony what ai ai app
is rat using sh that's a
secret sh don't give away all of our
secrets I mean he uses a bunch of them
there's so
many um but I mean but I mean it depends
on if it's the image if it's the sound
if it's the so the laboratory is full of
AI machines peanut butter podcast or
whatever the [__] that [__] is there's
tons um
of peanut butter podcast oh my God uh
why do I say such stupid [__] I don't
know you [__]
decide um Proverbs says are you are you
a Tony or Anthony I was called Tony my
whole life
and Tony's my
nickname but it comes from the name
Anthony which is my middle name actually
but I've been I was called Tony my whole
life my family called me
Tony my my family now like when I was
growing up I was called Tony in
school um so Tony is my is my name you
know it's a nickname but it is my
name it is my
name Jane do says what did I Miss oh
[__] I don't know how long you been gone
how long have you been [__] been gone
H should I
recap no let's not
recap let's let's go to a break when we
come back we'll watch some more Clips
don't go anywhere I'm going to get a
drink take a break we'll be right you
take a break don't go anywhere though
don't touch the dial as they say on
radio we'll be right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetoric iCal question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy de's Tammy by the time we reached
DC we was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and i't even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
[__] we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome
back to your daily antifa meeting here
at the antifa headquarters corporate
headquarters Studio
666 the Tony Michaels podcast every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific I promised you a video of Nikki
Haley and my friend uh
Christopher on Twitter Christopher web
has a mashup of some of these videos
which that is the best one I think that
is out there so this this top one that
we're going to hear from is from just
the other day and then from 2019 and
2010 so you're going to get to see the
evolution of Nikki Haley's dumb [__]
so let's go for it what was the cause of
the United States Civil War I think the
cause of the Civil War was basically how
government was going to run the freedoms
and what people could and couldn't
do oh [__] that's great how great is
that what what do you think what do you
think you think she's going to be like
no the I just said what the Confederates
said but they said it different okay
they said it they said that they wanted
to own human beings okay that they as
the government want to make sure that
rich people can own other human beings
it's I just said it
differently oh these people are so dumb
keep going
dummy I mean I think it always comes
down to the role of
government it always comes down to the
role of government and if the government
gives uh some human beings the
permission to own other human beings
it's called
slavery what a [__] idiot this is the
same stupid States
rats Civil Wars about the states rights
yeah it's about the state's rights to
allow people to own other human beings
what the [__] don't you get wh how don't
you people know this [__] yeah it's
about states rights and the federal
government saying the state does not
have the right to allow one human being
to own another that's what it was about
yeah slavery [__] idiots say about
slavery well I want you to say a lot of
stuff what do you want me to say about
[Laughter]
slavery next
question
I love it I love it cuz last week last
week there's a bunch of people on
YouTube and a bunch of people on the
[__] news and a bunch of people like
yeah Nicki Haley's goingon to win Nikki
Haley's gonna win yeah she's definitely
going to win she's the one that's most
marketable get the [__] out of here and
Bravo to the guy asking the simple
[__]
question what what was the Civil War
about huh question yeah
I got a couple questionss for
her hey
Nikki when you're talking about states
rights to own humans owning other humans
are you for or against humans owning
other humans next question H all right
so speaking of states that want to allow
humans to own other humans which is
called
slavy do you think that they should be
able to secede and start a war with that
said government huh question okay all
right I didn't think so let's see what
else let's see what she said in 2019
Nikki Haley says the Charleston Church
shooter hijacked the ideals some believe
the Confederate Flag represents here is
this guy that comes out with his
Manifesto holding the Confederate flag
and had just
hijacked everything that people thought
of everything people thought of when
they see a Confederate flag like I don't
know uh rich white plantation owners
owning black people what the [__] what
the [__] are you people talking about
okay so for many many years in this
country people in the South gaslighted
themselves about the Confederate flag
right and it and it's clear as day uh a
good example is a really good [__]
person like one of the best one of the
the best people on the [__] planet
okay and I don't say this lightly and
she's the queen of country music her
name is Dolly Parton now if you haven't
like went and watched Dolly Bon do what
she does best which by the way is not
singing and she is a damn damn good at
singing okay she's damn good at it but
what Dolly Parton is really good at is
connecting with people that's what she's
really [__] good at she's better at
connecting with people than anything
and she is truly authentically good to
the deepest part of her core and it is
something that um we should be building
monuments to Dolly Parton because she
truly is the queen of country
music but Dolly Parton had a a a show it
was a theater now there's several of
them around the country but the one that
I'm familiar with is in my home state of
Missouri in Branson now this theater uh
it's a show about the North and the
South it's about the Civil War and she
called it Dixie Stampede now a lot of
people let her know that hey that the
word Dixie really has a lot of [__]
negative condentation to it to black
people in this country because it
reminds them of U slavery so you should
take that her friend said you should
take in consideration that word on your
theater Dolly Parton
did did the work of going you know what
that I didn't know that because I'm
white and no one has ever said that to
me and let me know that I've been
gaslighting myself and she took the
[__] name off her theaters all the
print all the merchandise took it off
the theaters the whole nine yards and a
lot of people still give Dolly Barton
[__] because they do the
reenactments but I don't think the
reenactments in in and of themselves are
inherently racist and the reason why is
cuz the north won the North won and we
don't have
slavery that's a thing that's why she
took the Dixie off the
Stampede because Dolly Parton looked
inside of herself and said hey I'm a
good person if I'm a good person I
shouldn't be having this on my [__]
theaters and she took it down because
one friend mentioned to her that that
probably she should
consider that name is offensive to some
people and Dolly Mar took that to heart
I think she spent I think she spent
something like $1.2 million to undo that
name which honestly I I don't think it's
about the money really um but she did it
in um of her own [__] valtion and she
did it because she cared about what
people thought about that word not
because she didn't want to appear to be
a racist because again people still
claim she's a racist because she's she's
having these reenactments in this
theater that's now called stampede they
just Dro Dixie and they call it Dolly
Parton
Stampede but again they claim that she
is but she did not do it for that reason
she actually did it for the reason that
you should do it is to be like you know
what I don't want to offend some people
so I'm gonna take that down I'm I'm not
going to do that anymore Dolly B just
say I don't give a [__] what would do
what would
do she would do a lot but Dolly Bon's
one of the and that's and that's a prime
example
of how someone takes something um from
the era of the Civil War and doesn't
know anything about it but clearly
clearly Nikki Haley doesn't understand
what the [__] flag represent and what
it means and she's acting as if some
racist some bigot is appropriating the
meaning of the Confederate flag which
was to S secede from our nation because
our federal government wouldn't allow
them to own slav
holy [__] it's amazing that she doesn't
know this and it's also amazing that
people out there said that she was going
to be the
nominee whoa whoa it's dumb as dog [__]
okay go ahead go ahead Nikki people saw
it as service and sacrifice and Heritage
you know for those groups that come in
and say they had issues with the
Confederate flag I will work to talk to
them about it I will work and talk to
them about the Heritage and how this is
not something that is this is something
that is a tradition that people feel
proud of and let them know that we want
their business in the state and that the
flag where it is was a compromise of all
people that everybody should um accept a
part of South Carolina same as so um uh
man librarian is pointing out that she
did as the governor of the the state of
South Carolina remove the Battle Flag um
from the capital grounds that was put up
there after the Civil War is to warn to
warn black folks that hey you may be
free but we still own your ass um that's
what it's for that's the symbolism I
don't know if you know that but that's
the symbolism of that flag is hey we may
have lost the war but we still get to
oppress you
okay that's the point and Nikki Haley
yes she did take it down because it
became a thing that she couldn't not do
but she worked her ass off to keep it
there and that's really the point isn't
it she worked her ass off to keep it
there kind of the opposite of what dolly
Parton did with Dixie the word Dixie on
Dixie Stampede someone mentioned a
friend mentioned it to her and she
thought about it and was like yeah
that's really [__] I shouldn't have
that name and she took it down almost
immediately as soon as she possibly
could really and and Nikki Haley fought
to keep that [__] symbolism on the
capital grounds
so yeah mighty No No Mighty liaran says
I mean she's full [__] in a rhetoric yes
I you're agreeing with me but I I did I
did I did you do bring the facts always
mind your librarian always brings the
facts I was just trying to bring up the
fact that yes I we agree on this she did
take down the flag but that's all
because it was it was untenable for her
so I appreciate you saying the facts but
I wasn't I wasn't aiming at you I was
just saying in
general we love Mighty librarian here
you guys should go visit the library of
democracy and what you should also do
why we're talking about the library
democracy we'll give them a little bit
of a grift here too uh it's not really a
grift it's free so there's no grifting
in it you just win every argument I
think they're still are they still
reading this book are you guys still
reading win every argument or is there a
new book I know in February we're
supposed to have Rachel boff's book
um U um and she's gonna actually join
the book club there on Discord
so yes um yeah there's still reading
they're still reading win every argument
by mini Assan uh in the Discord you guys
can join the book club let me show you
where to go uh to do that and then we'll
we'll get back to some of these clips uh
here is where you go you got to go to
the antifa headquarters first and then
you go to the Tony
michaels.com you go to Theon
michaels.com hit subscribe at the top
and then pan on down a membership the
book club link is right here you will
have to join the Discord but again if
you you can just do the book club stuff
or you can do all the other hellscape
stuff that they do on Discord yeah they
do listen that's kind of like the
digital virtual uh antifa corporate
headquarters over there on the
Discord that's like the virtual meeting
and it's a 24-hour antifa meeting all
day every day in the Discord if you want
to do that so just go to Theon
michaels.com pan on down hit book club
and you guys can join the book club and
they listen to an audio book uh too so
you guys can do that join all the folks
over there on Discord and join the book
club as well so there's the pitch thank
you mighty librarian and all the people
who participate in the book club
including theren who I think helped the
and skip over there on Discord who helps
get the the book club going with the
audio books and the books every day if I
missed anybody I didn't mean to
just um yeah I got a grift I got a grift
oh you know what that's good idea let's
grift um it's getting cold outside you
should
um your hot chocolate will taste much
better or your coffee whichever you
prefer and even my cat hates Ted Cruz
and even my dog hates Ted Cruz coffee
cups let go to the Tony michaels.com
that's so you go to Theon michaels.com
and you just hit the my dog hates Ted
Cruise merch button right there you can
also get your [__] fanny pack to hold
your antifa membership card which sounds
like we're going to have on that store
as well if you want to get
official antifa corporate headquarters
membership
card to carry in your [__] fanny pack
or you could get your my dog hates T
Cruz hoodie and you could carry it in
the pocket of the hoodie or even my cat
hates take Cruz ready they're all over
there on the store so there you go
there's a little bit of grift got a
grift give it to me give it to me give
it to me give it to
me oh boy all right let's go back to the
clipse I'm tired Nikki Haley she's
irrelevant let's go let's go to um a
different clip here I want to show you a
clip of lur
bber the Bobo Bobo the
Clown oh hand jabby hand Maul as we call
her here on the the Tony Michaels
podcast um I don't want to know what's
happened in this kitchen to be quite
honest it makes me wonder what has
happened in this
kitchen all right let's listen to how
she wants to suck the juice out of
Colorado's forth today I am announcing
my candidacy for the 2024 Republican
nomination to represent Colorado's
fourth congressional district in the
United States House of Representatives
it's the right move for me personally
and it's the right decision for those
who support our conservative movement
this is the right move for Colorado for
us oh so she is gonna handball is gonna
go to Colorado forth and apparently go
watch Beetle Juice because it's the
right move what move do you use
doggy is that the right move I don't
know missionary I don't know [__] 69 is
that the right move is that the right
move handma I don't know [__] I don't
know since the first day I ran for
public office I promised I would do
whatever it takes to stop the Socialists
and Communists from taking over our
country oh [__] that's great this is
great since the first day she took
office her main goal is to stop the
Communist and the Socialists from taking
over our government oh my god oh [__] I
listen you know how um everyone says
blood poisoning is from mind conf this
[__] she's saying is from mind com as
well guess where they started before
before Hitler and the Nazis really
started to demonize Jewish people so
they could exterminate them they started
with communist like that's how that's
how it all started cuz I don't know if
you know this but commies Communists are
like the arch enemy of fascist right
I mean they always get it wrong they're
like you're a commi you red Kami bastard
that's why I make fun of it and I say
we're a Kami Falls
Missouri
because and there isn't that many
communist there just isn't communism
kind of sucks if you want to know the
honest truth I know a lot of people on
the left thinks communism is cool but
it's really stupid it really is it's
dumb most of the time it it snowballs
into authoritarian ISM because it's it's
really a radical way of constructing a
society of telling people what the [__]
they can do because that's kind of the
thing with Communism is your your they
take away your [__] Liberty um so
there's not a lot of commies out
there there's not there's not a lot of
communist out there because most people
don't like communism because they don't
want their [__] rights and their
Liberty taken away from them [__]
dummies and that's the other reason why
communism most of the time snowballs
into authoritarianism because everyone
else stands around going well why can't
we decide they're like well
because because because I said so and
that's
authoritarianism so it's really stupid
but that's from mine COV that's how they
snowballed oh Vermin Vermin who do you
think they were calling Vermin the
communist that's how they snowballed we
should be we should exterminate Jewish
people that's why they snowballed it
into it because a lot a lot of Jewish
people who were coming to Germany from
Russia were
communist communist just like the Nazis
were
socialist okay all right go ahead that
means staying in the fight but it also
means not allowing Hollywood Elites and
Progressive money groups to buy the
Third District as a seat that they have
no business
owning so she literally says the quiet
part out loud she's like we the
conservatives own it okay we own the
seat we get to tell the constituents
with our money who they're going to vote
for do you see that do you see how she
admits that almost
openly she's such a [__] I don't know
I don't know who writes this [__] for
her I don't know if she writes this [__]
this is the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
of in my life that her her great hero
move is to move to Colorado's forth
because a bunch of Hollywood Elites are
buying Colorado's forth look you dumb
[__] Adam Frisk almost [__] beat you
you beat him by less than 500 before all
the Hollywood Elites started giving him
money which is not the case Adam Frisk
is is outraising her with small
donations and again with the [__]
lies in these idiots you can't stop it
but that's the [__] crazy part about
all this is that her hero move to make
sure that the Hollywoods don't buy the
the Colorado's third is to go run in the
fourth so she's basically telling people
in Colorado's Ford [__] you f i don't
care about you I'm not going to fight
for you I'm goingon to go fight where
it's easy to fight okay that's where I'm
going to I'm going to take my fight to
Colorado's third where I won't lose to
Adam what a [__] boneh hen all right
keep going there hand mall I will not
allow dark money that is directed at
destroying me personally to steal this
seat D Money destroy you you were giving
hand job and I'm not against it I'm
really I'm really honestly I'm not
against it like most leftists are like
oh my God I can't believe she was giv a
hand job in the theater I mean it was
dark he was all [__] sexed up she's
all sexed St they probably had [__]
drugs and alcohol in their system so
it's not surprising that she's given
some dude a hand job that had a boner in
a goddamn theater okay it's not it's not
that [__] uncommon for people to get
all sexed up in a dark theater where
they've been drunk or high and start
[__] feeling each other up okay it's
dark all right it's a dark room you know
she had her she had her tits out he
probably had a wood and it was showing
through his britches and she was [__]
feeling him up this is what humans do
humans have sex they want to touch each
other they want to feel each other they
want to [__] each other this is how it
happens okay especially when it's
[__] consensual they really start to
get sexed up okay all right it's not
[__] unusual and really honestly um
Lauren bartt could use a some good
[__] sex to try to get this [__]
brainworms out of her goddamn head if
you want to know that God's honest truth
but here's the thing here's the thing is
this is so stupid to act like someone
else is sliding her because they're
telling the truth they're showing a
video where not only are you feeling
some guy up in a [__] theater but
then you get all [__] you know who I
am when they kick you out for breaking
the rules which listen again I'm not
saying you should or you shouldn't go in
a theater and start jacking each other
off but what I am saying when you get
caught jacking each other off in a
[__] theater you're probably going to
get kicked out you [__] bonehead
yes even if you're all sexed up no one's
watching or you don't think anyone's
watching it is possible that you're
going to get kicked out of a [__] of
a [__] theater by trying to feel each
other up it's gonna happen it's probably
gonna h i mean I've never been kicked
out of a theater for that I probably
should have been but I never have been
just saying and I'm not going to sit
here and be like oh I can't believe I
can't believe she felt some guy up in
the theater and they were kissing each
other and he was grabbing her boobs I've
done that [__] in the theater okay so
I'm not going to sit here and act like I
haven't it's the dumbest [__] ever and
anyone out there who's [__] sitting
there saying they haven't done that
they've done that like I've never I
can't believe that oh my God it's so
egregious I can't believe that I can't
believe that two humans that were all
horned up [__] doing drugs
drinking vaping probably probably had
the THC in their Vape pan and they
probably [__] before they got there
they planned on [__] after I can't
believe two sex Steed individuals who
wanted to [__] each other we're feeling
each other up in a dark theater get the
[__] out of here with that [__] the
point is she's blaming it on someone
else what why are you blaming it on the
media this is like Joe Rogan yesterday
blaming the media because he's an idiot
get the [__] out of here with this [__]
blaming someone else for your [__]
for your hand jobs keep going it's not
fair to the Third District and the
conservatives there who have fought so
hard for our victories how hard like how
I I mean like like [__] rock hard you
know what I mean like [__] just solid
you know what I mean like rock [__]
hard how hard
Lauren
oh oh God I hope I hope she I hope she
wins the primary honestly at this point
that's what I'm that's what I'm going to
say I think she's going to lose the
primary but I'm hoping I'm hoping she
wins it CU if she wins it then there's
might be a good [__] chance there
might be a good [__] chance that a
Democrat
wins I'm just
saying okay let's let's keep going let's
see if she gives any more uh [__]
[__] or sex references in her little
speech here she really didn't think
about some of this stuff let's go of
which I'm incredibly grateful personally
this announcement is a fresh start
following a pretty difficult
year fresh start you know
what a fresh start for having a very
difficult year I mean it's it's almost
like my it's almost like my money shot
moment here it's almost
like I don't know [__] what do you want
from me I listen look at this kitchen
all right you know for sure this woman
right here has been bent over this
counter watching porn on this TV right
up here okay I almost
gu it almost guarantee it that her and
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with it [__] she should own it really
honestly instead of giving us this
stupid [__] video from her kitchen
where she's she's abandoning her
constituents in the the third because
she's not going to win so she's going to
go try to win and and Juice the beetle
in the fourth listen Lauren the video we
want from this kitchen because I'm I'm
I'm gonna tell you the honest truth I'm
gonna tell you honest truth and Howard
Stern said it too I bet she is a really
good [__] you wouldn't want to stick
around for the conversation before or
after but I bet she is damn good in bed
I bet she knows exactly what she's doing
100% exactly what she's doing and I
guarantee you that there's a much better
video that has been taken on whatever
cell phone she's taking this [__]
video from um in this kitchen with porno
up on this TV cuz there's a TV right
here above I what looks like a either
this is a bathroom or a pantry room this
is probably where they keep the condoms
I don't know I'm just saying I'm just
saying I'm sure I don't have any proof
of it but I'm sure she's been [__]
down in this kitchen I mean it looks
like a kitchen that is in a porno I'm
just saying if you go watching up porn
you'll find it
there it's the end of the year it's the
end of the it's December 28th what else
do you want me to talk about what
else oh boy Lauren Boer Lauren Boward is
a big Maga loser hand Maul hand Maul she
is we've got one more thing I want to um
I want to share with you before we go I
do have uh the map of a Kami Falls uh
that's that's Mississippi but yeah this
is um Kami Falls
Mississippi um not Missouri welcome
welcome to Kami Falls Mississippi and
then here's the other one um Rick Comm
to Kami Falls Mississippi
veren what whatever that means this is
great this is great can we can we 100%
Missouri is Mo by the
way there probably is a commi Falls
Mississippi too I'm not going to lie
there's probably a commi Falls
Mississippi were you confused by
Mississippi and Missouri you're like
well they're kind of the same they start
with an m they got a lot of sisses
sisses in it is that what you were
thinking rant like it's a or was it that
the AI doesn't know the difference May
is that what it is the AI doesn't know
the difference between Missouri and
Mississippi is that what it is I don't
know maybe the AI doesn't know
and
oh commi
Falls commi Falls located the antifa
corporate headquarters right here
broadcasting every single weekday your
daily antifa meeting for two full hours
on YouTube Facebook twitch and now
Instagram live from the antifa corporate
headquarters from commi Falls Missouri
or Mississippi whichever it's kind of
the same state it's kind of the same
[__] you know what I mean same kind of
thing thing same kind of thing thank you
thank you for getting us that that
welcome sign rat and thank you for being
here today don't forget tomorrow we're
going to be doing a show tomorrow uh
we'll do some kind of bonehead thing
tonight and then I think we'll do
bonehead next year with Gabe Sanchez the
guy with the last name Sanchez so we'll
do um we'll do bonehead of the year next
next week we'll do a bonehead rendition
tomorrow so you guys get to vote and we
get to do bonehead have fun tomorrow is
going to be the last show of the year
and then next week we'll be back on
Wednesday so tomorrow and then we're off
Monday and Tuesday we will be back
Wednesday full steam ahead for
2024 same time same place tomorrow Surfs
Up [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow Tony
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking give it to me give it to me
give it to
me
I mean I I've made fun a little bit of
the vice president saying that you know
now she's went from being the borders
are to being in charge of posting gas
stove selfies but on a serious note
folks like myself who own a gas stove
are concerned that the administration
really does intend to do things like try
to get rid of them well and you should
be you know I on a gas stove too I don't
care if you're on natural gas or like me
on propane gas or whether you don't pull
my finger gas you the administration and
the federal government should have no
impact or input on what you have for a
stove but this is I mean I've
made